Film Courage: What's the most amount of time you spent
on a screenplay? Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter/Author: The most amount of time?
Boy those are years ago, not a lot of
time now. But I think it would be my
fifth spec script and only because I stopped on
page 60 and that was because of a
personal tragedy and I didn't know if I
was going to be able to go back to it
because I felt guilty about not going
through my grief some someone passed
away and it took me probably six or
eight months of stopped on page 16 to go
back and finish that first draft so I
had good momentum and then it was just
you know I was knocked out and just
couldn't focus but that experience
worked its way into the script because
there was loss in the screenplay as well
so it was really you know really found
its way in there in the successive you
know drafts after that not in the first
obviously because there was so many 60
pages but it was you know upon this is
the other drafts it really you know so
that I think that would have taken the
longest time but I don't you know from
writing assignments because there
there's a schedule I really like to get
a script done you know in obviously the
time that the contract states but just
as in my own spec to I don't want to
work on it for years you know I want to
have something available and do
successive drafts and then have
something to be like okay this is the
one that at least that I can show people
so I would say you know three pages a
day is a feature in a month easy it's
very doable and people say oh I worked
on the script for a year again you can
work on it for a long time without doing
pages
you know me because you're doing the
research you're doing you know all these
other things to get to that point that
could take time as well you could spend
months that particular script I did
spend months of research before I even
started you know because it was a dream
so I had this little like I was talking
about all I had it was it was a little
book like a little scene and I was like
well that's interesting but what like et
what about if someone was left behind
and so started building out characters a
story and you know it was historical
movies so there had to be some research
done so you know it's not always like Oh
write the script in a month it could
take like the iceberg there's a lot of
work that has to under the surface that
has to be done so I don't know if I've
answered your question
when you finish the one screenplay where
you stop with the 60 pages
yes something bad happens yeah then
there was this guilt how did you feel
once you finish that screenplay because
you said you took some of that emotion
well I I felt it was almost that it was
almost a mission you know to finish it
because the person would have wanted me
to do that and so that helped me get
through the guilt of like oh how could
it be writing this script you know when
this happened and somebody passed away
and so I thought you know this person
would want me to go back and do that
they wouldn't want me to honestly waste
my time but you know what I mean
on this this thing and so that helped
motivate me to go you're okay there's no
guilt and finishing this thing you know
so yeah cuz you never know you know when
you're writing your life can get in the
way and does and you know it's this
other thing that you do and if it's your
vocation you know that you get paid to
do it
you know you can't just toss it aside
and say oh well I mean you know stuff
stuff happens in life too sure but like
we were talking about earlier but using
your personal experiences you don't want
to have to go through that stuff but if
you do you know you tap into it you know
use it it's real it's real it's
authentic you know its authenticity
actors love that kind of stuff you know
and so writers should do cert as well
the script that you're referring to
wasn't that the first screenplay that
you sold it was yeah it was a world war
ii picture called lob remember April and
they bumped bumped around town for a
number of years and it finally got
option and they made so it was like
seven years from the time that I wrote
the first draft - first day of
photography and not like I say not every
project is that way and some never get
made and you never like I said that we
were talking about earlier you never
know the journey of a project if could
sit around for years on a shelf and then
someone discovers it or it could sell
tomorrow for big money
you know there's everything in between
so yeah what did that experience teach
you because didn't you have a day job or
you had another job during that time
when you had - yeah yeah oh absolutely
during those seven years sure and I also
wrote other specs and you know the whole
the whole gamut what it taught me was
that you know if if you really believe
in a script you know don't don't give up
with it now you have to see the writing
on the wall but this one at Oldham
almost won the nickel fellowship and I
say almost that year they picked the top
eight people you know out of 3,500 you
know to get the fellowship and my script
was in the top 20
so they actually called me and told me
that and I was like oh wow okay and so
from that I was you know I was able to
give some people who read it and this
and that but the the personal connection
I had at the time with this company that
was just starting was the
way in it wasn't from an agent it was is
my own networking so that's also
important that everyone says I'm looking
for an agent you know and your own
networking I think is almost more
important because it's the face-to-face
I've got you and you know an agent
unless they're just starting doesn't
need a 25th client in the way now some
agencies are actually signing with the
Writers Guild about you know about
everybody had to fire their agent you
know who is in the guild and some
agencies are signing now to say okay
we're gonna follow the you know the
rules but you should be networking you
know that's the most important thing is
to have because that wasn't sold by an
agent it was my own connection into that
company so that's that's what I learned
as well we were were you networking like
what let you don't have to name the
place but was it was kind of enough no
it was my friend's friend who was in the
business so my friend had said oh my
friend is an assistant to blah blah blah
and they were just starting a brand new
company they already had a company cut
two million years later that assistant
became president of that other company
and then he went off and left to have
his own company so you see how you know
to me it moves on so every assistant is
not gonna be an assistant forever you
know they want to look at the rolodex
and and find that amazing script to
bring to their their producer and say
look what I found and you want that
script to be yours and you want that
decision to be somebody that you have
contact with because they're gonna grow
and move into producers and whatnot you
know and that assistant because of that
script then as president the company
hired me again and again and then when
he went off to so it hired me again you
know so I mean that's how you build that
none of that was from an agent or a
manager now they're great to have but
but I see people I brought my secret I
got I get you know it's like you should
be out networking you can't you can't
rely
your career and give it to somebody else
you're the one thinking about it 24
hours a day you know like networking
where um you know around town like in
there's there's functions all the time
is a international screenwriting
Association has a final draft has them
staged 32 has them meetups get-togethers
things like that so just or just be out
you know like you're seen in Los Angeles
you never know who you're gonna run into
and then there's no there's no studio
gate there that says they're not getting
in I mean seriously I mean my friend was
chatting up someone and they were the
assistant to one of the biggest
producers in town now nothing happened
but then we were talking about the blood
okay but they could have said oh that's
an interesting story because they're
looking for that interesting story right
and they want to be the one who brings
it to the mucky-muck and says look what
I found now they have to read it first
it has to go through hoops but you know
over I mean it has to go through hurdles
but isn't that much better than you know
oh I'm struggling writer and I you know
here's my stuff and the agent or agency
gets back to you six months later you
know I mean those those can get you to
different levels absolutely necessary
but my point is don't think that's the
end-all be-all
those will come when you're ready that's
the thing they'll come when you're ready
they won't come when you just finish you
for a screenplay let's just the most
amazing thing you know and then they
already has bids on it and stuff like
that you know so don't stress it by
getting representation right away that
only comes Plus you have to be a
workhorse if an agent is gonna take you
on or manager they want to see that
you're working like okay you got this
this is good we need to work and look
change what oh yeah yeah you got another
and what else you working on you have to
be working not just the one script throw
in the ring and go am I done
no you're not done it's just the
beginning you think desperation
scares a lot of would-be deals away yeah
you did consents a desperate writer a
million miles away when you're like you
know the best place to be is where you
don't need it where your life doesn't
rest upon this hundred pages you know
that's you know that's where it's and
plus the desperation can work into your
writing too you know so no it's it's
hard you know desperation and fear and
those all things you gotta you know
you're gonna constantly keep in check
you